I will now introduce you to the concept
of tension so it's tension is really
just the the force that exists either
within or applied by a string or a wire
when it's usually lifting something or
pulling on something so let's say I had
a weight let's say say I have a weight
here and let's say it's it's a hundred
Newtons 100 Newtons and it's suspended
from this wire which is right here let's
at eight let's say it's attached to the
ceiling right there well we already know
that the force you know if we're on this
planet that this weight is being pulled
down by gravity right so we already know
that there's a downward force on this
weight which is the force of gravity
force of gravity and that equals 100
Newtons right but we also know that this
this weight isn't accelerating right
it's actually stationary it is it also
has no velocity the important thing is
it's not accelerating so for the but
given that we know that the net force on
it must be zero by by Newton's laws so
what is the counteracting force well you
could you could you know you didn't have
to know about tension to say well the
strings pulling on it right the string
is what's keeping the weight from
falling so the force that the string or
this wire applies on this weight you can
view as the force of tension and that is
also another way to think about it is
that's also the force that's within
within the wire and that is going to
exactly offset the the force of gravity
on this weight and that's what keeps
this point right here that's what keeps
this point right here stationary and
keeps it from accelerating that's that's
pretty straightforward tension it's just
you know the force of a string and and
just so you can conceptualize it you you
you know on a guitar the more you pull
on a on some of those higher was the
thought you know the really thin strings
that that sound higher pitch the more
you pull on it the higher you the
tension it actually creates a higher
higher pitch note so you've dealt with
tension a lot I think actually when do
they sell wires or strings they'll
probably tell you the tension that that
wire strength is
which is important if you're going to
build a bridge or a swing or something
so tension is something that should be
hopefully a little bit intuitive to you
so let's with that you know fairly
simple example Don let's create a
slightly more a more complicated example
so let's take the same weight instead of
making the ceiling here let's add two
more strings let's add this green string
let's make that green string there and
it's attached to the ceiling up here
that's the ceiling now and let's say
this is the wall and let's say there's
another string right here attached to
the wall so my question to you is what
is the tension in these two strings so
let's call this t1 t1 and t2
well like the first problem this point
right here this red point is stationary
right it's not accelerating and in
either the left/right directions and
it's not accelerating in the up/down
directions so we know that the net
forces in both the X and Y dimensions
must be 0 my second question to you is
what is what is going to be the offset
because we know that already that at
this point right here there's going to
be downward force right which is the
force of gravity again right the force
of the weight of this whole thing we can
assume that the wires have no weight for
simplicity so we know that there's going
to be a downward force here this is the
force of gravity right the whole weight
of this entire object of weight plus
wire is pulling down so what is going to
be the upward force here well let's look
at each of the wires this second wire t2
or we call it w-2 I guess the second
wire is just pulling to the left it has
its it has no y component it's not
lifting up at all so all of the so it's
just pulling to the left so all of the
upward lifting all of that is going to
occur from this first wire from from t1
so we know that we know that the Y
component of t1 so let's call so if we
say that this vector here
doing good different color because I
know when I draw these diagrams it
starts to get confusing so let's let me
just actually use a line tool so I have
this and if you can see let me make a
thicker line so we have this vector here
which is t1 right and we need to figure
out what that is and then we have the
other vector which is its Y component
and I'll draw that like here all right
this is its Y component we call it we
could call this t1 sub y and then of
course it has an X component too and
I'll do that in in let's see I'll do
that in red and this is once again this
is just breaking up a force into its
component vectors like we've a vector
force into its X&Y components like we've
been doing the last several problems and
these are these are just trigonometry
problems right and so we have we could
actually now visually see that this is T
sub 1 X and this T sub 1 sub y oh and I
forgot to give you a important product
with the problem that you would that you
needed to know before solving it is that
the angle the first wire forms with the
ceiling that this is 30 degrees so if
that is 30 degrees we also know that
what these this is this is a parallel
line to this right so this is started 30
degrees this is also going to be 30
degrees right so this angle right here
this also going to be 30 degrees and
that's from our you know we know about
parallel lines and alternate interior
angles we could have done it the other
way we could have figured out we could
have said that you know this if this
angle is 30 degrees this angle 60
degrees this is a right angle so this is
also 30 but that's just review of
geometry that you already know but
anyway we know that this angle is 30
degrees so what's its Y component well
the Y component let's see what involves
the hypotenuse and the opposite side
let me write sohcahtoa top because this
is really just trigonometry sohcahtoa in
blood-red so what involves the opposite
and the hypotenuse so opposite over
hypotenuse so that we know the sine let
me switch to them the sine of 30 degrees
is equal to t1 sub y over the tension in
the string going in this direction and
so if we solve for t1 sub y we get t1
sine 30 degrees is equal to t1 sub y
right and what did we just say before we
kind of dived into the math we said all
of the lifting on this point all of the
lifting on that point is being done by
the Y component of t1 right because t2
is not doing any lifting up or down it's
only lifting it's only pulling to the
left right so the entire the entire
component that's keeping this object up
keeping it from falling is the Y
component of this tension vector so that
has to equal the force of gravity
pulling down so this has to equal the
force of gravity that has to equal this
or at this point full so that's 100
Newtons and I really want to hit this
point home there because it might be a
little confusing to you we just said
this point is stationary it's not moving
up or down it's not accelerating up or
down and so we know that there is a
downward force of 100 Newtons so there
must be an upward force that's being
provided by these two wires this wire is
providing no upward force so all of the
upward force must be the Y component or
the upward component of this force
vector by the on the first wire so given
that we can now solve for the tension in
this in this first wire because we have
t1 t1 what's sine of 30 sine of 30
degrees in case you haven't memorized it
sine of 30 degrees is one-half so t1
times 1/2
times 1/2 is equal to 100 Newtons
divide both sides by 1/2 and you get t1
is equal to 200 Newtons t1 is equal to
200 Newtons so now we've got to figure
out what the tension in this second wire
is and and we also there's another clue
here this point isn't moving left or
right it's stationary so we know that
whatever the tension in in this wire
must be it must be being offset by
attention or some other force in the
opposite direction and that force in the
opposite direction is the X component of
the first wires tension so it's this
right so t2 is equal to the X component
of the first wires tension and what's
the X component what is going to be the
tension in the first wire 200 Newton's
times the cosine of 30 degrees right
it's adjacent over hypotenuse and that's
square root of 3 over 2 so it's 200
times the square root of 3 over 2 which
equals 100 square roots of 3 so the
tension in this wire is 100 square roots
of 3 which completely offsets its and
it's to the left and the X component of
this wire is 100 square roots of 3
Newtons
to the right hopefully I didn't confuse
you see in the next video